[Music]
shortly after you and your brother were
born
your father and I divorced and we each
took one son obviously I got second pick
I have a twin brother hey brother
[Music]
finally meeting you your discomfort is
al-arian
so how are things career-wise haha great
who let the most wanted villain just get
away you're fired
social great crashing it I brought you
here to continue the family business
Yoli is in your blood and the group can
boobs I left that life behind me
I understand hmm I wonder what this does
holy-moly become a villain Mogambo
pretty nice
what did you guys do today there's
always a blinder nothing
my beautiful
she
hello what about that fool Wow Oh girls
here I'll make you learn to appreciate
me differentiate me
we've been waiting a long time so what's
was it it was so fluffy I thought it was
from a day
oh you two are villains ah I mean hello
[Applause]
[Music]
hello GRU how's your transition coming
you know from world's worst villain to
world's worst agent oh that's hilarious
you should be on TV what that's right
you are but then you get canceled
Oh what about us why Oh Charles oh yeah
dance fight this is on expect day
well you never got to go to honeymoon so
we made you dinner
it's a luau we got pineapples and
coconuts hey hey yeah I love you gotta
be fun hey yeah I got you got you got it
up
Oh madam and Monsieur the gummy bears
for my idea hmm looks too good to leave
and eat am i right ah but I made it for
you
Oh God soup I love the combination long
gummy bears is meat
you saw for real like your heart would
it look like
oh you bet dis relic Andy wasn't it was
so fluffy I thought I was gonna die
[Music]
are you okay yeah I'm fine
are you really real sorry
one little mama bear Anya you know Papa
labas aha
I wonder what this does
[Music]
holy moly dams villain wheels flick oh
hey you want to take her out for a spin
just for some fun Sarah so far 103
seconds able to stand in the nuclear
blast are to the down
[Music]
I am NOT enjoying there I'm going in
take the wheel
oh let still don't see why I can't go
with you hey hey we discussed it now is
not the time to mess with the plan
[Music]
[Music]
haha hey Mahler what I told you you're
supposed to stay with the ball
oh I didn't think you meant that
wouldn't always what other ways could I
have meant it huh alright let's move
just follow my lead I'm okay oh I miss
dominions hold on to me don't let me go
guys
[Music]
[Music]
their use a week
[Music]
so how are things career-wise but I are
at the beginning of the movie crew loses
his job so he's kind of down on his luck
we're going to be fine
I want to hell since you don't have a
job I got two old dollars ah but you
meet a long-lost brother and you're
drawn back to something in your past
when going back to villainy they are
like two little kids up to no good she
kind of gets a little suspicious with
her plotting so you two are villains now
ah I mean hello sweetie and there is a
villain the likes of which we have never
seen
Balthasar Brad it's some kind of monster
wait that's not a mobster that's a man
wearing shoulder pads it's really
interesting charming and funny it's a
lot
[Music]
haha okay how could you let Balthasar
brats just get away you're fired
he really did to snuggle in I miss what
are you doing since you don't have a job
I just wanted to help
ah excuse me oh hey could you oh of
course
now as I was saying oh good my seriously
oh I really must have a word with you on
behalf of your twin brother drew why
twin brother my brother music I can't
wait to meet my brother
[Music]
doesn't love this come look at him
Alvin hair would make you better look at
this face
oh so mad you might need to be a little
wife oh sweet talker this place is
amazing it's nice like gasps you're I'm
not really interesting Masek groovy
leaves in your blood it's a gross and
boobs
you ready to continue the family
tradition you and me
no I left that life behind me just one
[Music]
I'm going in
[Music]
I'm okay
we're going back to the beginning of
this third Despicable Me group receives
news that he has a brother named drew Oh
ready to be villains together no I left
that life behind me just one nice mmm
I called the black one when they get
together it's hilarious how about we
steal the largest diamond in the world
it's a very interesting dynamic between
the two of them also cuz they're both
played by the same person wait did we
just being in each other's sentences
drew is sort of the alter ego of group
he's very light very silly
who doesn't love this guy look at him
open hair would make you better
what GRU makes things much more
seriously it's not like stealing
lollipops whoa I've impressed my kids
friends by pulling out the GRU voice
every now and then you're dead getaway
driver
Oh with any luck I'll be able to pull
out the drew voice and get the same
reaction it's go time
[Music]
turn around from put you back you up a
pouch uh can I take it up a notch oh my
god Wow
take em out let me take us I'm a sting
[Music]
step back heights music
[Music]
[Applause]
some kind of monster wait that's not a
mobster that's a man wearing shoulder
pads there's only one super villain
whose fashion sense is quite dictated
free Balthazar flat I want every agent
on the scene immediately in its cozy are
closing fast
yes wait why what did you call us brucey
you know GRU and Lucy pushed together
GRU see aha
I like it but not a lot I don't like it
[Music]
get away
that's what do you think get the ready
[Music]
hello haha what about that Wow Oh girls
dance fight this is not over
[Music]
day to you happy birthday dear day
[Music]
when I was first asked to do the first
despicable me I love the idea of this
lonely despicable person who was bad but
intrinsically had a good heart the first
movie group became father the second one
had the relationship with Lucy and how
that started and then in this third one
getting the chance to create an entirely
new care this does not mean that we are
going back to being valence ah did you
flick amico okay just one iced mmm I
call the black one you need a long-lost
brother and you're drawn back to these
latent tendencies of evil when going
back to villainy the story is funny and
I'm really proud of being a part of this
world so you two are villains now ah
I mean hello sweetie Tito potami lunatic
at CTU litigious a Palazzo a toñito
Callen a goal a Macarena Palacios pop
open elder say panic Agusta Manila del
nella mousse - Ella - Chama Cha mocha
co-captain laka casa de la la masala
Papa mama low capicola crystal Armitage
a packet a mulatto cabacas´s illallah
yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]